6 14. every day we go over the numbers
and every day they keep going up
tracking coronavirus cases has become a
sad scorecard on the expanding pandemic
but there are some places where covid19
is merely a ghost
in gold field they love to live in the
distant past
the ghosts the mining days when 20
thousand people called this outpost home
i'm a floozy today this saturday patty
huber beth stood on u.s 95
in her turn of the century attire i do
not want to dress like this every day
it's hot
there was supposed to be something
special today the annual gold
field days there would be vendors and
booths all along the street but
it was canceled you can imagine why not
very many people stopping
the coronavirus there just wasn't enough
time to be able to put anything together
today less than 300 people call
goldfield home
in all of esmeralda county there are
less than a thousand people
and they all have one thing in common
none of them have the coronavirus
esmeralda county is the only part of
nevada without
one positive test in fact it's one of
only 34 counties nationwide with no
cases it's almost like it's out there
william belts runs the chamber of
commerce
is it really real yeah because it's out
there you know even though you know it
is
frustrating as it is he knows goldfield
had to cancel its big day
this is not a very rich county so we
depend upon little things like that that
brings people here
but there is an impact of the
coronavirus shutdowns on
rural towns where there isn't much of an
economy to lose
the shutdown here doesn't mean what it
does in vegas
we don't have a home depot we don't have
a walmart we don't have
so where what are you shutting us off
from as a former nurse
huber beth tries to remind her neighbors
how serious the pandemic could be in a
small town
even some people who in the past may
have scoffed at it
they're now being much more cautious in
goldfield it's hard to find a trace of
the coronavirus
importantly there are still no cases but
and belts wants it to stay that way
we're just not going to get it
and indeed hopefully it stays that way
69 of esmeralda county's just
974 residents have gotten coveted tests
state officials do plan to expand the
testing there
in the near future it was a